all right um let's now ask questions
about any questions from the panel and
while you're gathering that I'd like to
ask the question that was left over from
the first panel which is what are your
tips to journalists working for news
organizations which do not have the
resources or the commitment to do this
kind of long-term in-depth reporting one
thing i want to say because I I'm an
editor of a significant newspaper and
part of the Hearst group and I actually
compared to a lot of my colleagues here
actually get to see the financials and I
came from a newspaper group that it's
been publicly or newspapers publicly
reported that lost 17 million dollars
last year and that's the sort of
downside of journalism that you read
about the truth is that probably most
newspapers and news organizations in
America make money The Associated Press
makes money my newspaper is profitable
so I wouldn't get us down on the future
of this business as a lot of people have
having said that since we make money
what do we do that's special and unique
and a public service to our communities
and it's worked like this I said earlier
tonight that unless a reporter really
wants to do a story chances are it's not
going to get done so really it's an
individual responsibility that all of
you have you know if you think a story
is really important it's really you're
the one who's going to determine whether
it's going to see the light of day
Michael barons tips for those who are
not lucky enough to be working for the
Seattle Times just a few weeks ago some
of us actually were in Nashville and I
was in a room like this with a bunch of
editors who asked the same question
these are mostly mid-level papers and
the advice that I have is look around
you the stories are all around june i
was talking to award-winning reporter
for USA Today she goes that movie you
know I see dead people that's how some
reporters are with stories like
everywhere I look I see stories and I
just can't understand when people say
they can't find stories so look around
you I mean there there there that truck
that says true world foods is driving
down the street that's owned by the
unification Church the Moonies their
little number one sushi supplier United
States when there's a police car crash
there's a database for free sitting in
Washington DC from the national
transportation administration allows you
to track every fatal police chase in
America my point is is there are tools
that we use in this field and you go
have to go out and learn those tools
most of them are free you just have to
learn it to their you have to learn how
to use them so when you look around you
you'll know what you're actually saying
yes much i would say um don't worry
about it in colombia i don't need to
tell you guys don't worry about your
medium I mean jeez you know ah I don't
know I don't know what newspapers are
gonna look like in 10 years I don't know
what the AP he's gonna look like in 10
years and I sure as hell don't know what
network television is going to look like
in 10 years but I do know this you know
there's always going to be a guy there's
always going to be somebody who's
willing to pay money for to know
something that they they didn't they
can't find anywhere else and there's
always going to be a mic bears is always
going to have a job right because if you
can tell a story and find something out
that nobody else is going to do you're
going to be fine there will be jobs for
you if you are going to write what you
know the press conference that happened
yesterday for tomorrow's paper and
you're gonna write it a little bit
better than everybody else maybe there
won't be a job for you but if you're
going to tell me something that I didn't
know there will be a job for you and
then you go to your nepotistic yes yeah
I mean you don't don't just come with
hey I have an idea i mean come with
stuff that they can't turn down I mean
what editor is gonna say it's a great
story you've got everything there but no
I mean that's this just not that
shouldn't be happening in newsrooms but
make sure you go to them with with what
you have and have
Stefan do some pre reporting just you
know don't go to your editor with you
I've had a great idea you know it's
coming it's coming to do so do some
reporting I mean I you know do some
reporting on your own time you know so
you're still being able to produce what
your editors expect of you especially in
your first jobs you some on your own
time early in the morning after work you
know playing with data at home don't
tell anybody um but and then when you go
to your editor you have a you've got
something great play with data at home
is the tube man yeah thanks for the
encouragement my question is probably
particularly aimed at Craig but actually
a lot of these stories deal with very
distressful situations very personal
matters and intimate moments and I was
wondering how you go about telling those
stories in a way that to tell them with
dignity instead of in a way that might
feel voyeuristic Craig dignity is
supposed to be a Boyar ism um I think
it's I think it's a you know just
getting started like I said before it's
a matter of trust and you know what when
I when I approached my subject I sort of
you know treat him with respect I treat
him you know I try and be genuine and
honest and you know I hope for the same
thing back and you know I know that I
remember a time when you know like while
I was working on the story about Scott
and and like I had spent an afternoon
with them it was a pretty hard day for
him and I just remember him saying he
was like I'd like before I left you know
we're saying a buying his like Craig am
I gonna look like a big baby at the end
of this and you know that's you know so
i think that sir and I just said you
know I don't I don't think you're a big
baby you know so I hope not you know I
but but yeah he put himself out there
and it that
what you know it is it's a
responsibility to tell the story right
without you know without pushing it to
that love that that the other side where
you're like totally taking advantage of
somebody and again I think that comes
from your heart more than anything else
go no you're okay no did you did you
show um Scott your work as I was right
you were working no I am did he get to
see it before no no no no I'm trying to
think if there was ever you know I
remembered every now and then like
especially with a long-term project
people are kind of interested like every
now and then I would show them like a
picture that didn't have anything to do
with him like on the back of my camera
or something but like when her camping
or something i don't think i ever showed
him a picture like during the actual
project I think he was interested in the
ones from the apartment which diving
from the his girlfriend but I don't
think I showed him money no I didn't I
didn't think it was he didn't really ask
a lot either i mean when i worked on hey
i just i think once you get beyond that
that sort of courtship and that like the
early part of the relationship you know
i think you just once we get to that
trust thing he he wasn't really
interested at that point i did tell him
when it was going to be published like
it because it was published online and
so I told him before I told anyone else
I was like okay it's going to be live at
you know ten o'clock tonight if if you
want to take a look Eileen you were
talking to people who'd been spied upon
I mean how how do you get them to trust
you hear you where you know reporter
from DC going to this Muslim communities
and asking them questions um well you
you do it the way you do any sort of
reporting I mean you go and you present
yourself for who you are and you ask
them questions you give them time to
talk I mean for me meeting them as
community I introduction to them in New
York was as we were getting ready to
move out our our initial story I was
working on a follow-up about all of the
outreach the over outreach that the nyp
does NYPD does with Muslim communities
and it is going on across the country so
you have so many politicians and and law
enforcement saying I've got this Imams
number of my phone I can call them well
you know there's we call each other we
know each other there are these
relationships and this has been a big
thing you know since since nine eleven
that this is going on and so I was
talking to a lot of the people who were
doing this outreach or you know getting
their picture taken with the mayor and
the police commissioner and basically
asking them how they felt how it was
working I mean what's the goal here are
you you know what do you get out of this
do you feel that they're listening and
and so that's that you know as we
started getting these reports and doing
more reporting I mean I would go back to
these people that I met initially and
also I had a bit of an understanding of
how these relationships work in other
parts of the country and and saw a lot
of differences in New York so it's it's
not you know if there's not like a
single model that you use but you do as
a reporter you go out you talk to people
and you figure out who to talk to next
and you sort of adjust your your
strategy like that and you're you know
always upfront with that I mean there
were stories that some were very very
very unhappy with me over um and Eileen
especially in the Muslim community
Eileen listens really well I mean good
les there's a good listener um pauses
that you know reporters who are more
gregarious I might feel compelled to
fill um Eileen just lets him sit and and
lets people work through their thoughts
because this is a complicated thing
you've walked in somebody's house or
business and put a police file down and
said hey that's you what do you think I
and and I think that that was one of the
real Joy's about working with
with eileen is just being able to you
know sort of let her watch her do her
thing Michael did you want to weigh in
on this question because I think it's
something we all confront and from my
experience it's absolute honesty and
it's something we've already said here
but the first thing I tell people is I'm
a reporter from the seattle times before
i say anything because they're expecting
subterfuge they're expecting me to try
to hide what my agendas so it's absolute
honesty and i actually tell people why
they shouldn't talk to me sometimes and
and it's very effective particularly you
know you have to educate these victims
that they're going to live forever on
the web now you know it's a different
world in many ways and angeline Burrell
her family picture is going to be here
at Columbia University long after the
story's been published I mean it's going
to go around the nation it's going to
live there forever so it's telling them
that you have to understand and so the
purpose in a way I get sources of talk
is I give them a sense of mission here's
you know if I was you I probably want to
go public that's why I tell a lot of my
swords I don't know if I'd have the
courage but if you want the world to
know about what you went through then
then you're a better person than I am
probably and I admire you for that and I
want to be there to tell your story and
it's that bluntness at honesty it works
you know 99 percent of time thank you
there was someone standing here a while
ago who wanted to ask a question yes go
ahead I had a question about the
methadone story I was wondering how you
negotiated the issue of poverty i think
it was obviously clear that there was
that this was disproportionately
affecting poor people but i thought it
seemed like that there was a fair amount
of restraint in how you presented that
that facet of the story you know not to
get into the technical parts but we
brace it basically took census data
where he brought it down broke it down
into quintiles and we made five
different income categories and then we
matched dots you know by by geographic
location to what quintile they fit in
you know to these income categories and
so we had a database editor named Justin
Mayo at the paper he's an expert that
this kind of thing and he's the one who
divvied up the dots by income for us and
then again we went to professional
epidemiologists and healthcare
professionals and asked him to look over
him
theology and also in the project we
published a little how we did a box on
the web where we explain what coding we
use how we differentiated between
illegal use of methadone versus legal
use of methadone and those sorts of
things so I think what I think he was
saying how did you deal with the fact
that a lot of these people are poor and
you guys did this so well and handled it
in the story so well that is tended to
be poor uneducated families and you're
going in and saying I miss reading that
you're going in there with a deft hand
and saying you know hey I'm a reporter I
want to put your picture of the paper we
had 99 percent people turned us down
because of the poverty issue they did
not want to go public with the fact that
they were poor that this was a horrible
traumatic that's why finding the story
of Angeline Burrell was so precious to
us and even within that family there had
been a huge fight within the family
about whether to go public the mother
went renegade with their own family
decided to go public because she had
this sense of mission that she wanted
the world to know what happened to her
daughter but it is an issue we found
that there was one anonymous story in
the project where there were two sisters
who were in a crash car crash one got
methadone one Dennett one dies one
doesn't and the family just refuse to
let him go public because unfortunately
and this sounds very prejudicial perhaps
but a lot of low-income families also
had a lot of other issues in the family
maybe the dad has been arrested for DUI
maybe the brothers had a robbery
conviction they were scared at all this
laundry would come out and their
families based on the one little story
so that's what we confronted it was a
huge issue we again absolutely honestly
we told him exactly what we're doing and
why a lot of people turned us down but
fortunately some said yes yes my name is
Paola I was wondering about the
methadone whether the data also showed
dosage like how much on death
certificates we could not see what the
actual dosage was we had to go back
after we identified who the families
were we took basically the list of all
2,700 people who died and we call the
families one by one not all 2700 we we
categorized them i'd say we called about
150 of the 2700 and that's where we
asked for medical records and try to get
dosage at this point what the death
records did show us was whether it was
accidental
or not and it showed us what else was in
the body so someone had methadone in
their body and cocaine that's a family
we're not calling but if it's just
someone had methadone only and maybe
with a with a an anti-anxiety drug or
we'd see sometimes with a sleep disorder
you're not suppose to be getting
methadone if you have sleep apnea those
are the families we can call then we
learn dosages afterwards but with
methadone it only takes a small amount
to kill you so how do the word their
deaths for heroin you know we mean
people off of heroin would there be a
similar pattern we looked at methadone
deaths linked to heroin addiction and
believe it or not it's not that many
because there are so many safeguards we
actually have those passage in the story
for you to get methadone at a methadone
clinic you're not allowed to take home
your medication your first couple weeks
that you use it you have to take it
right there in front of somebody and you
have to come back the next 24 hours to
be observed but if you're a general pain
patient they give you a 30 day supply
and they send you home and so that's why
you don't see that many people OD'ing on
methadone at a methadone clinic yes John
I'm wondering about the issue of
collaboration I know at least three
these were collaborative projects so
what are the kind of advantages
disadvantages of collaborative reporting
and how do you negotiate that yeah I can
i yeah we definitely you know once I
said we had a team of five reporters and
two editors it really worked on this and
it was a partnership between the
investigative team and the education
team and I think that was really a great
model because you had your education
reporters who had all the sourcing and
then you had all your investigative
people who had you know a lot of you
know a lot of ideas about how to go
about creating databases and and just
some of the ways that you go searching
for records and so in terms of that I
think that the partner should work
really well and also I can talk about
like when we went out to do some of our
reporting to visit some of the families
we usually went in teams to with the
idea that that perhaps whoever we were
interviewing student parent whatever
would react or you know interact better
with one personality vs
another and we all had very different
personalities and different styles and I
think that that kind of worked for us
that we were able to do that and so
naturally though when you're working on
a project you have people your
personalities there were times when we
you know kind of had some battles I
remember when it came down to writing
part one in particular the three of the
three of us John myself and Kristen all
had a certain way that we wanted to
write part 1 and we were trying we
decided Mike's laughing because he knows
that's why you have an editor so we got
to negotiate it and you know it in the
end I think we finally probably Tris
would probably changed a word or two you
know but we finally I think I think
going through that process is painful as
it was actually made the story better
and yeah Mike did um you know way in the
end it was the referee and you know got
us through it I think one of the points
touched on earlier in dealing with
people and Sue just gave another aspect
of it is is people do have different
personalities and when you're
interviewing somebody who was reluctant
to talk of getting a story out of them I
always felt that you had to establish
some sort of common connection or
empathy with them I mean yes you are a
reporter but people also had to suspend
their wariness of the fact that you
might be a reporter and communicate with
you on kind of a one-to-one basis and so
I know after a while with some of my law
enforcement sources over the years they
kind of forget I was a reporter and you
know they tell me stuff that they
probably shouldn't have told me but it
was just that there was a long-standing
kind of relationship so I think that's
important when you're dealing with
people you know the actual sources there
people when people you get to know over
a period of time and establishing
rapport with them is an important part
of the job do do any of you want to add
to this I mean just you know look
everything we do
you in our little group down in
Washington it's collaborative I mean I
sit from here to Mike for Adam Goldman
and it's closer there's just a little
cubicle wall between us and maybe from
you know from here to sue to my lean and
the poor people have to sit between us I
mean cuz other if you sitting at my
computer like did you see this she's
like oh my god and there's people have
you on IM and it so they're right even
getting a whole part of a conversation
and you you know you if you can get a
group of people right they have no idea
what's going on um and if you can get a
group of people who just like working
with each other and you know there's not
i mean we we had our we have blow ups in
the newsroom and I tell Adam to you know
whatever and you know I mean Adam and I
live across the street from each other
our wives have babies at the same time
we walked to work to each other we go
home together we work next to each other
it's not healthy um I but I mean if you
can get people working together in in
that kind of a team situation where I
mean there's just nothing like and
there's nothing as much there's nothing
you all do in your careers that's more
fun than working on a great team and the
products gonna be so much better than if
you did it yourself all the time I just
wanted to say one more thing real
quickly um I think you know one thing to
remember when you are working with the
team is yeah you argan and personalities
and you're going to have some issues but
what you want to always keep in mind is
that any energy that you spend you know
fighting with each other or you know
battling each other going behind each
other's backs or whatever is energy that
you take away from getting your project
done and there's no way that you can
really do something of this magnitude
frame these projects that I don't think
unless you put all that aside and focus
on the goal all right our last question
for the evening hi my name is Sonya with
so many of these stories are very heavy
topics very serious critical issues and
you're following sources around for days
months they may or may not be stable um
yet you have to gain their trust and you
know show empathy so that you can
produce the story and tell their story
but how do you balance that and put
approach with your own personal
well-being so that you're still taking
care of yourself and you know you're not
affecting the story so much with your
own reporting on it you know what I mean
it's why I tell sources it's a sense of
mission and that's what drives me and
that's what gets me up in the day and
it's because what I what I do I believe
is important you know I think that's you
know what I want for my kids I tell I
don't care what you do in life as long
as you believe that whatever you're
doing is important and so how do you
differentiate yourself I I don't think
you do and you touched on empathy and
it's it's the ability to have empathy
with the people that you're reporting I
consider it a privilege tender their
lives and I enjoy you know living a
little bit of that pain with them in the
sense that it helps me better understand
the story I don't know I think we're all
dysfunctional I'm I used to be 120
pounds so look you know I'm not not a
poster child for stability here but yeah
just joking great I tend to be a little
obsessive myself I am previously worked
on a story about a kid joining the army
and I spent two years on it and I like
totally obsessed over like because he
lived like an hour from like all his
buddies from high school and he would
come home every weekend and so every
weekend I was like gee I wonder what
kind of trouble Ian's going to get into
this weekend and hey I don't think it
ever became unhealthy but I was I was
sort of teetering on the edge there
where maybe maybe it was but
unfortunately with this with the wood
with Scott you know I actually had some
personal life some personal life durand
and some good things going on in my life
I am I think she stepped outside but I
got married and had a baby while I was
working on this project and so yeah you
do have to sort of take some time for
your own and I think that's what you're
asking about like mentally how do you
hi
as a friend yeah well you know Scott
actually Scott and I had that
conversation a number of times I mean I
remember one time is like oh yeah that's
right i'm just a subject you know so i
mean we actually you know but i mean you
know i worked on that project for like
nine months and you can definitely that
line can get a little muddy you know
like and you just have to be very aware
of it yourself as a journalist you know
and i think that you know you you you
think about it now so i mean if you're
working on a story you'll think about it
then and you just have to be aware of it
and sources do become friends but
friends are wrong to right i mean just
cuz this i mean a source does become a
friend but you can't give more weight to
that because you know you've known him
for 20 years you know you so I mean you
run into that I mean you covered a beat
you know and you still covered
counterterrorism to beat and you know
you could drinking with people and no no
never yeah I mean there and I think if
you're gonna ask somebody to be
available to take your phone call in the
middle of the night they you know have a
right to want to know a little bit more
about you so when you're getting to know
people i mean it does get you know a
little personal they want to know about
your background a little bit i mean it's
a conversation you're building a
relationship with someone but we have to
remember that this is you know this is
what you do for your job and you're
gonna be up front with them um all the
time about you know if they're saying
something that's off the record I mean
you need to honor that um and you know
it's up to you how much you want to tell
them about yourself but really I've I
found just acting like a human being
with people i mean if somebody says i
have to cancel an interview because my
kids sick when you talk to them i mean
don't you want to know how the kids
feeling ask questions like that be
normal yeah and want to know like don't
ask because you think it'll get you
better information has cuz you really
want to know because you don't check
your humanity at the door when you take
these jobs I mean far from it we're
writing these four people
for robots so yeah note that's the
ending noticing we're writing for people
not robots we like we sometimes say
around the germs and cooler there are no
issues there are only people and I want
to thank the panel for the outstanding
job they have done tonight and
deconstructing they're terrific
achievements and I want to thank Sheila
Cornell for her brilliant job of
moderating the panel and I want to thank
you for showing up and paying some such
deep attention and asking such sharp and
inquisitive questions and now on to the
presidential debate